my son died in my hands life has no
meaning to me now says this woman as
mothers around the world celebrate
mother's day many in ukraine are
thinking of children lost her hope for
other mothers is to see their children
survive
some will more than 300 civilians have
now been rescued from the azov stall
steel plant in mariopol the city key to
moscow's efforts to create a land bridge
between the crimean peninsula and parts
of the eastern donbass region controlled
by russian-backed separatists
[Music]
as of regiment leaders say the steel
mill was still under intensive shelling
saturday and there are hundreds of
troops still inside many of them wounded
needing help
while in luhansk the death toll at this
school bombed by russia saturday has
climbed to as high as 60. 90 were
sheltering inside
it is about staying in power
and vladimir putin knows that in the
history of russia
when governments lost a war
they usually lost
power a very different scene in russia i
think that vladimir putin seems to be
hung up on may 9th and i'm not quite
sure why he's been so foolish to be
blunt rehearsals are underway for
putin's victory day celebrations on
monday a holiday commemorating the
soviet union's defeat of nazi germany in
the second world war with speculation he
could use the opportunity to either ramp
up fighting or declare victory over
ukraine i think there's slightly too
much optimism in western capitals that
the momentum is going to stay on
ukraine's side sunday g7 leaders held a
call with ukraine's president as a group
they're promising to further isolate
russia economically as well as either
ban or phase out russian oil a lot more
difficult for european nations than
north american but they're promising to
do so in a quote timely fashion